what's up guys I have some bad news for
all you other small YouTube content
creators out there just a few hours ago
on YouTube you only needed 10,000 total
public views in order to make money from
google adsense this was quite reasonable
and not very hard to reach and a much
better alternative for small creators
who wouldn't be able to get into
networks however today
YouTube has increased that amount of
four thousand hours of Washington in the
past twelve months and at least one
thousand subscribers to be able to earn
money now
this is completely unfair to so many
people this prevents so many people from
even starting to make any money on
YouTube and could turn good careers of
starting a channel this is also going to
lead to so many people with possibly
good potential to quit
it makes YouTube very tough to succeeded
for example I'm a pretty small channel
but I have about five thousand views but
I've only been serious for about two
weeks on YouTube now now I was hoping to
get into the affiliate program in the
end of January but now it may even take
the other end of the year or more for
example an average youtuber has 1% of
the total views on the channel as the
subscribers for example if a YouTube
channel has 1 million subscribers then
it would have about 100 million views so
now since YouTube is requiring 1000
subscribers you would have around
100,000 views before you even start
making money the average CPM on issues
is 2 dollars which is $2 for every cup
of users so as a result in those 100,000
views you would have earned $180 when
you subtract the 10,000 views that you
are
now $180 isn't that much to sustain life
but for kid you'd rivers for just doing
YouTube as a hobby and using the YouTube
money as pocket cash are people who
would like to see a small check just
with some inspiration keep trying to
make that check bigger well they won't
get that anymore
now let's see it finally get to 100,000
views you probably still haven't reached
4,000 hours of watch time probably for
example my Irish watch time is about one
and a half minutes as a result I would
need at least one hundred and sixty
thousand views to be able to reach the
goal as you can see
YouTube has raised the bar to the insane
amount they see that this is - we're all
the bad actors but this is really just
closing door to so many people
and all of you guys had already got food
for 10k views well you're out of luck
because you are going to get unapproved
on February 20th this year if your
before you were giving about $20 about
revenue before you get to get paid now
they're giving up $300 and have been
friends for so much longer
some reports such as the verge are
saying that the Mogan pulse recently
same with the forest is it's caused all
this happening because our cases were
very angry and she was able to post
inappropriate video and still make money
off of it YouTube has promised these
advertisers but they were rectified such
issues from happening again and they
didn't kick him off the Google prefer a
program so this may be a strategy from
YouTube to stop inappropriate viral
videos to earning money and only keep
him long-term stable YouTube channels
alive but fortunately yen
it is too small finding youtubers who
are affected if you guys think isn't
completely unfair that make sure to drop
a like on this video and I've guys I'm
only a fifth hit a hover so watch time
and 33 subscribers so if you'd like to
help me out then make sure to subscribe
and share this message with your friends
and from now on be more lenient when you
guys are subscribing to small YouTube
channels because they really need the
boost that you guys can give them I may
have forgotten something in this video
because I wanted to get this out to you
guys as soon as possible so if you guys
have anything to say make sure to leave
in comments below for example you guys
did that the sub for subs will increase
not because some people might have
enough Washington but don't have enough
subscribers say they want to get more
subs to that if you guys have any
thoughts that make sure to put in the
comments below I do read all my comments
so I hope I'm looking forward to seeing
what you guys think but that's all I
have for you guys this time and until
next video bye